good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock nearly two years into the
pandemic and a stark reminder it's not
gone away with the emergence of the
omicron variant
new rules come into force this morning
requiring masks on public transport and
in shops and the booster program is
being rapidly expanded with the uk
aiming for half a million jabs per day
but just how concerned should we be
about this new variant and could we all
be getting more restrictions for
christmas we'll speak to the health
minister one of the country's leading
scientists and the boss of the
international air transport association
in the show this morning also to come
we'll be chatting to this man the mayor
of london sadiq khan after it's revealed
that two cases of the omicron variant
have been found in the capital that's at
about 20 past eight and
they're a place to heal
not just on a personal level but as
we've come to understand at a global
level
the green shoots of recovery with ben
fogel will speak to the tv presenter and
adventurer about his new campaign to
preserve the woodlands
right around the uk it's tuesday the
30th of
november more masks more booster jabs
more testing the new rules coming into
force in england today to try to slow
the spread of the new coving variant
i'm live at one of the busiest train
stations in the country to see how
commuters fare with the new mask wearing
rules on public transport
saying goodbye to the queen the
caribbean island leaving its colonial
past behind
and i'm here in bridgetown where prince
charles has acknowledged the appalling
history of slavery in the caribbean and
described this as a new beginning for
the island nation
a court in myanmar defers a verdict on
elected leader aung sang
who was deposed in a military coup
prosecutors accused british socialite
gilead maxwell of preying on vulnerable
young girls at the beginning of her
trial in new york
[Music]
good morning everybody masks are now
compulsory in shops hairdressers post
offices trains and bosses the new
measures are intended to slow down the
spread of the new omicron variant of
coronavirus with 11 cases found so far
in the uk
so let's take a look at what is changing
all international arrivals must now take
a pcr test on or before day two and
self-isolate until they receive a
negative result
and these 10 countries in southern
africa are now on the red list meaning
that people returning from there have to
quarantine in a government approved
hotel for 10 days costing more than 2
000 pounds
in england face coverings will become
compulsory on public transport and also
in shops in the in line with the rest of
the uk
uh but unlike scotland wales and
northern ireland people in england won't
have to wear a mask in pubs and
restaurants
in schools staff and pupils in year 7
and above are strongly advised to wear
face masks in communal areas unless
exempt
tonight teachers and pupils in wales
will have been told they should wear
face coverings in indoor settings
educational and child care settings
should also continue to encourage staff
and students to test twice weekly using
lateral flow device tests
cool
will be there'll be a small written test
on that later on the health minister
jillian keegan is here good morning it's
a lot for people um to take in are we
already too late though to stop this
virus this uh variant i should say well
i mean clearly we've got some cases in
the country but we have acted as quickly
as we could possibly could i mean we
found out actually i think we're the
first country to find out and we we
acted straight away but this is the
nature of this you know we're working
internationally but you know normally
when you find a variant you know the
reality is it exists already um
obviously now what we've got we've got
the five cases here they're doing you
know contact tracing on the ground uh to
make sure that you know we isolate
people who've been in contact with those
cases but of course we've been here
before you know this is a variant that's
here and all the measures we're putting
in place are because we don't
underestimate new variants you said five
cases i mean what do we know how many
cases we've got we've got five here's
six in scotland as of this morning but
you know i'm sure that will rise i mean
where are the five cases the five cases
i think they started i'm in london yeah
there's a couple in london camden and
onesworth in london um then there's one
in chelmsford brentwood area um and uh
yeah
another couple as well um okay i think
in nottingham as well nottingham yes
actually they were the first two
nottingham and yeah the brentwood area
joe biden said there's no cause of panic
are we in danger of overreacting well
we're trying to get that balance in
proportion um and it is difficult
because it's it's unknown so we need to
buy some time so our scientists can work
with the world's leading scientists to
just basically sort of figure out what
we know it's very transmissible by
looking at the uh but we don't know you
know whether it will work with the
vaccine the vaccine will work all the
other treatments etcetera so the
scientists do need some time for that um
we think we've got the balanced and
proportional response to it but we will
review it in three weeks that'll give
the scientists enough time to hopefully
give us some insights then we're going
to be chatting to willie watch actually
in a short time and he is not at all
happy yes and that's why we're trying to
get the balance right with the with the
uh with the variant obviously we put
some more countries on the red list but
you know we're not doing some things
which would potentially you know shut
travel down all together we're very much
trying to keep uh things going keep
buying you know keep people traveling
etc but of course we have put a few more
restrictions in place and you know how
long that red list will stay in place
well they are reviewed every three weeks
so the red list is always reviewed every
three weeks and so we'll continue to
because of course there are quite a lot
of cases in europe you're not thinking
of adding them to the red list as well
again that will be continually looked at
it will be looked at all the time and
obviously if you get some flare up in
cases then you know then we can take
immediate action if we need to so what
about in the meantime what about the
booster
what's going to happen to uh when uh
when is everybody going to be able to
have a booster if they want well they're
working on the plan right now um so
obviously we took the jc vi advice the
nhs are working on opera
operationalizing that so in the next
couple of days that will come out the
booking systems etc you'll be get you'll
be contacted by your gp that's usually
the first step um but we'll be releasing
that the next couple of days we'll have
the opera the plan and i'm pretty sure
it will go in age order again so we'll
do the top age groups you know the older
people first i mean obviously most of
the old people we've done 17 million
booster jazz when you say old people
i've had
yeah i've had my boosters so steady on
uh but by the end of the week everyone
will know when they can have a booster
well the next i think probably will
happen is the next cohort will be
invited forward and then they'll be
given uh you know some some time frames
so you know but within the next couple
of months we are pretty good at this at
you know we are standing up these these
operations so we do know what to do but
we just need to give the nhs a bit time
to operationalize
you know the new because we we're
doubling the eligible people more or
less who are who are due a booster now
so how tricky is that going to be given
that
already we have i think at two and a
half million boosters a week something
like that you want to do another million
boosters yeah a week have you got enough
staff
well we've used in the past you know
nhs staff obviously the community
nursing staff of
the pharmacies the gps volunteers
retired doctors and nurses we've used
that pool of staff in the past so i
guess they're going to be looking at
which of those they need to um you know
bring back into you're going to mobilize
an army of um of nhs people yeah i mean
you know there's a lot of i mean i don't
know you know lots of lots of uh in my
case we had lots of retired doctors and
nurses we had lots of community
volunteers as well who had first aid
training so we did have a lot of that in
the first and they'll get the call up
again well they'll look at what they
need to do um but you know
we do have you know the facilities we do
have the people and we do have the
vaccine so they'll just be putting the
plan together to see what's what's going
to make most sense what's going to
optimize do we know if this vaccine's of
any use whatsoever against israel
i mean obviously it will be of some use
what we don't know is is is how this
will you know we need the scientists to
look at that that's again a couple of
weeks the scientists have said they need
a couple of weeks to do all the testing
um of this against you know all the
various vaccines that we have plus the
vaccines plus the boosters but of course
the very very best thing you can do is
come forward get your first jab if you
haven't had it second jab if you haven't
had it and your booster when you're due
could be that we're completely
overreacting
i'd rather overreact than under react at
this point i think we've been here so
many uh times that you know we've got
this fantastic wall of vaccine now we
want to keep that we want to strengthen
it
to you know we'd rather be stronger um
to be able to you know face any new
variants and i think we have all the
things you know we have all the
capability to do that so that's what
we'd rather do um
the clinically vulnerable are being
asked to come forward again could we
then could they find themselves in a
position where they're going to have to
be jabbed every three months
i i haven't heard that um but i think
you know clearly the clinically
vulnerable are the people that you want
to make sure have
as much of the protection as possible
okay how will we know
if we've come into contact with an
omicron variant
how will we personally know well you
probably only know from the pcr test
that's the other reason the pcr test
omicron though do we um
we we would know the pcr test is where
they do they send that off for the
genome sequencing that's where you find
out if you know but not involved not all
of the um
labs that it's sent to are able to find
out about whether it's omicron or not at
this stage the the genome sequencing is
the second so they then go to the labs
and then they send them off to the labs
so i'm not 100 sure what that process is
going to be but the the reason we've
introduced pcr tests for travelers is
because we want to get that for genome
sequencing yeah so but my point is you
know you could have come back um you
could have had your uh test uh it would
be positive you would have found out
within 48 hours then i'm guessing i
don't know who who is it who is it test
and trace who would then say to me
you've been in contact with somebody for
well you have to isolate anyway right so
if you if you've tested i would
positively so how would i know whether i
need whether i'd come into contact with
somebody who'd had omicron
how would you know if you've been in
contact with somebody who's who's
how quickly would i know that i had been
in contact with someone who'd got
omicron i could have seen hundreds more
people before you you found out that
i've been in touch and then before you
knew well they're doing that right now
right in camden in wandsworth they're
going around figuring out everybody that
these cases have been in contact with
and they're getting so it's the contact
test track you know the test and trace
system which is getting all your
contacts finding out who you've seen
where you've been so you know that's the
manual process scheme only picks up half
of cases doesn't it
where have you got that figure that's
that's uh nhs figures
in terms of a half of the cases that are
um
a test and trace only picks up half of
cases and that all the testing that the
labs do cannot all pick up on micron
they don't all do we don't substitute
every piece we don't send every pcr test
for genome sequencing i would imagine
now they're going to be sending a lot of
those pcr tests for genome sequences
because we've got a new variant but in
terms of
now
the intention now is everybody that
those people have been in contact with
they will be contacting each one of them
so you know but we're going around the
houses to say that it's going to take a
long time to find out whether somebody's
got omicron and then you contact
somebody else and then before you know
it it's spread everywhere
well that's why we're asking people to
isolate you know that's why we're asking
people to isolate until they get a
result and then if they get a positive
result then obviously they're looking
into that result more uh clearly that
will that will obviously go for
for testing
that's why we're asking people to do pcr
so if it's positive it can be genome
sequenced it can be checked so that's
the i mean the processes will be put in
place now but that's the sequence of
events and we can do that we can do that
so that we can follow you know the the
test now obviously it gets to be
different i mean we've seen this before
with delta right and all the people that
are in contact with you if you've got it
will then all have to self isolate as
well so that would be six people or so
in the studio right now um
before you know we've got another
pandemic on our hands haven't we
well obviously what we don't know right
now is how fast this is going to
transmit and whether or how you know
what our wall of defense how how well
it's going to hold up that's why we need
that's why we're putting these cautious
measures in place that's why we're
reintroducing masks and we're asking
people to be more cautious we're putting
the pcr test and day two so that we can
you know we can get that data but yeah
right now we are being cautious we'll
know more in three weeks and of course
the key thing is but you acknowledge
there could be some level of pandemic
like we saw i think it really i think it
really depends what the scientists say
about our wall of defense about how well
the vaccines work you know there's a lot
of things we need to wait for them to
come up with the answers to that but i
mean clearly we know we've been through
every every variant of this i mean
excuse the pump you know we've been
through every kind of i think there are
a few more coming
yeah well possibly but we've been
through all of this in the past right
we've had to have you know
pandemics we've you know we've had we've
had to isolate people a lot you know
we're trying now to use all of the tools
i'm getting at is we could find
ourselves in that business position at
christmas time people are having to
suffer we're in a much better position
because of but you're always vaccinated
to self-isolate aren't you so yes
in a position where you can't see your
family at christmas no we're very very
much hoping that we can keep christmas
on track you know we're asking people to
isolate if they test positive with a pcr
test after they come back so they have
to well isolate until you get your
result basically that's what we're
asking people to do but of course um you
know we need a couple of weeks just to
work out how virulent it's going to be
and most importantly how well the
vaccines work but we are in a much
different position than any of the other
variants because we do have many many
many more people vaccinating if i've
come into contact with you and you've
got it i have to self-isolate don't i
yes okay so i we could find ourselves in
a position at christmas where you can't
see your family
well you obviously you could be it's
isolating over christmas you could be um
but what we're hoping is that you know
we keep these cases obviously
everybody's going to be contacted people
start the isolation
with or without this you could be
isolated
for christmas you know with with another
variant you could your boss the health
secretary said the christmas was on
track and it was all going to be
fabulous well of course of course
christmas is on track and actually what
everyone will be there what everybody
wants for christmas is if you haven't
had your first job come and get it if
you haven't have your second job come
and get it and if you have an added
booster come and get it when you're
asked that's all we want for christmas
and everybody contact with somebody
who's got omicron you might be saying
well today it's the same if you have any
variant today you know if you are
positive today then you it's not right
to say that then is he
well i mean
you you there will be some people who
will have to be isolating over christmas
there always was you know if you have a
positive test then you isolate you know
we've got um you know the the some
politicians isolating at the moment but
if you come into contact with people uh
you don't have to have self-esteem yes
but now you're saying you do with the
omicron very so all i'm saying to you is
we fight we can find ourselves in a
position where christmas is ruined again
hopefully not and it's you know we've
got five to let's be proportional and
balanced as we're trying to be we've got
five cases today
that will go up i'm pretty sure but you
know what what we're trying to do is
really clamp down on that as much as
possible obviously put in these
departure these these other tests
are all
and limit the number of people who are
in that situation i get it and i
certainly wouldn't want to be in your
position or indeed the health
secretary's position but all i'm saying
to you is as of this morning given that
we have to self-isolate now if we come
into contact with somebody who's got
omicron then we won't be able to see our
loved ones at christmas
um
well the chance of that right now is is
pretty low right we've got five or five
cases in the but that is that'll behave
sensibly as we've said to everybody you
know we're reintroducing masks we're
trying to you know
trying to delay you know the spread of
it so that we can buy the time for the
scientists to be able to
give us some facts really on on how well
we're protected with what we've done
already so that's what we're trying to
do and we're basically saying come
forward get your job get your boosters
the boosters will help we think they
will help um and we're just trying to to
you know to deal with this unknown at
the moment we very much hope that we uh
you know we have a christmas this year
you know we've had an awful experience
last year um and it you know it is it is
unfortunate timing from that perspective
but you know we very much hope keep your
christmas plans in place but of course
we will have to deal with it as you know
as the scientists um you know gets more
information to us we'll have to deal
with what they tell us okay we're out of
time sadly but it's good to talk to you
as always thank you very much thank you
for joining us thanks a lot
uh let's have a quick look of what's
happening as far as the newspapers are
concerned the financial times leads on
the uk widening the boost jabs program
to all adults in the hope of beating the
omicron variant
the metro front also reports on the
expansion of the booster jabs rollout
while the murrah carries the headline
new variant battle as the gap between
second and third doses is cut to three
months
and the guardian reports ministers want
the nhs to return to distributing 500
000 jabs every single day
still to come on the programme for you
as the government brings in new measures
to try to curb the spread of the new
kovid variant we'll speak to a member of
sage and immunology specialist at around
quarter to eight
speaking to the newly appointed shadow
levelling up secretary lisa nandy about
the latest reshuffle of labour's shadow
government and what that may mean
potentially for the future of the party
and we'll hear from the former chief of
british airways about the recent travel
bans in response to the new covid
variant and the impact on the tourism
and airline industries
i'm not sure whether christmas safe is
safe or not after that what do you think
let me know at cape early now barbados
has become the world's newest republic a
21-gun salute was fired just after
midnight marking the official end of
formal ties with the monarchy the prince
of wales acknowledged the appalling
history of slavery in the caribbean and
described it as a new beginning for the
island nation
rihanna mills is in barbados before she
stayed up specially thank you uh
rhiannon so tell us about what happened
today
well as you can imagine okay
independence day is always a big party a
big celebration here in barbados but
we've just witnessed a truly momentous
night as the caribbean island which has
been known to some for so long as little
england finally cut ties with the royal
family after almost 400 years deciding
to step out as a republic the first
commonwealth realm to do so in over 30
years and all watched on by the queen's
son the prince of wales who himself used
this moment to make a really important
speech going further than any other
member of the royal family by
acknowledging the real horrors of the
slave trade here in the caribbean
at national heroes square once known as
trafalgar square change was again coming
the prince of wales arriving to witness
the ceremony as barbados said goodbye to
the queen
this was the final time after nearly 400
years that a royal would oversee a
military parade in this way the moment
had come
the queen's standard was lowered and
then the countdown to midnight
barbados no longer a realm now a
republic
the new president dame sandra mason was
sworn in
first to pledge your allegiance was
prime minister mia motley who's pushed
so hard this new stage of independence
as those ties were cut prince charles
formally acknowledged the pain of the
past
from the darkest days
of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
the people of this island
forged their path with extraordinary
fortitude
but for those who've waited so long for
this they still want more
we want
tangible
actions towards reparations for our
people
for our nation and our country we have
we have endured a lot we have
still enjoyed the legacy of the enslaved
period covid meant that large crowds
were kept out and many are still divided
about what this really means
i think there should have been a public
vote
and i think it should have been decided
by the people and not by a few mps
everybody's out
celebrating
feeling proud
the royal family have always said this
was a decision for the people of
barbados after all they have been
independent since the 1960s and the
queen's role has largely been ceremonial
but this certainly is not the royal
family entirely stepping away they will
still be front and center when it comes
to maintaining those connections and
shaping that new relationship
rihanna was a surprise guest
this is a new chapter described by some
as a full stop on their colonial past
now two women at the helm writing their
future
[Music]
now for those who will be waking up in
the next few hours and even for those
who maybe haven't even gone to bed yet
there aren't any real kind of physical
changes that you'll see here in barbados
a lot of it is going on behind the
scenes of course things like the livery
on the post boxes is going to have to
change they'll no longer be the royal
police force it will no longer be her
majesty's prison but the important stuff
that's going on is still that transition
around what exactly the constitution is
going to look like and a big part of
that is because don't forget there was
no referendum here so people didn't
actually get to vote to become a
republic so there are still those who
are divided about whether this is really
the best way forward some people who
still see barbados as being very
vulnerable by taking this step things
like the climate crisis ongoing issues
around covid because they rely so much
on tourism here
but also that issue around reparations
when it comes to the slave trade as well
and those the big issues that prime
minister mia motley is now going to be
taking to the world stage as they take
that independent step forward okay
rihanna thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot meantime a military court
in myanmar has delayed its verdict in
the trial of the ousted leader angsan
tsuchi the country's democratically
elected leader was deposed in a coup and
arrested on charges of incitement
earlier this year shimon robbins is
standing by for us now hello to you uh
siobhan so this has been deferred for
now what happens to her in the meantime
well for the meantime ansan tsuchi will
go back under house arrest she hasn't
been seen in public since she was
arrested in february and to remind
people of what happened ansan suchi was
the very popular leader of the nld party
that party got a resounding victory in a
general election in 2020 and then in
february this year the military seized
power in a military coup saying that it
believed there'd been widespread
electoral fraud despite the fact there
hasn't been any widespread evidence of
that and from that point it detained and
sang so chi other leaders and the
president and since then she's been
facing a slew of charges and offenses
against her including these incitement
charges which were expecting a verdict
in today also claims that she breached
covert 19 protocol that she breached the
official secrets act
that she illegally imported
walkie-talkies now her supporters have
said these are absolutely bogus charges
thought up by the military to try and
keep her out of power because she is so
popular but it's very difficult for us
to know what's been going on in court
because the court has been held behind
closed doors quite recently the lawyers
who've been representing and sansuchi
and the president have been barred from
speaking to the press but we spoke to a
source today who's close to the court
who told us that today's proceedings
have been deferred we're now expecting a
verdict next week potentially on the
sixth but if she's found guilty of all
of the offences against her in the
future that could be a prison sentence
of more than a hundred years
okay wow goodness thank you very much
siobhan thank you
uh looking at some of the other news uh
for you this morning on the program here
we go 27 people drowned as you know when
their boat sank off the coast of france
in the deadliest single disaster on the
busy route twenty-one-year-old mohammed
ibrahim zaida was on board the
inflatable dinghy when it ran into
difficulties and began to lose air
but the people on the boat said no we
shouldn't go
this boat must reach britain tonight
then we moved away and ships in the sea
started to disappear
there was only this inflatable boat and
it started to lose air
the balloons had blown up the balloons
on the right-hand side of the boat were
now losing air
there was a pump inside the boat
so some people started a pompeii while
others were emptying water from the boat
later the people lost hope and gave up
when we started to sink gradually
the waves started to push us towards
france and the boats sunk and all the
people fell in the water
we started to hold each other's hands
each person held the hand of the next
person in order not to sink or drown in
the water
but with the sunrise early in the
morning the people couldn't take it
anymore and they all gave up on their
lives
my goodness me telling us what happened
in the channel um last wednesday night
thursday morning a quick look at the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
rain spreading from the west will bring
a brief mild spell but it'll be cold
again by thursday it's rather breezy and
damp at the moment with fog over western
hills but it's mild everywhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
yes 10 degrees warmer this morning when
i woke up now let's take a look at some
of the best pictures in the newspapers
for you this morning here we go
uh the times captures the winners of the
international wedding photographer of
the year competition look at those
they're great aren't they featuring
sweet and somewhat questionable
snapshots i love the one with the lamp
how clever is that i think that was the
actual overall winner uh the telegraph
tells us the sun may be responsible for
creating half of the earth's water and
it's featuring a woman in a bikini
taking what looks like a freezing dip in
the lake district yesterday morning and
the mail brings us a glimpse at a
record-breaking 11 stone 5 pound halibut
captured
in norway
no it surf's pop in the braz in the
brazilian city of natal this weekend
when the surf dog festival took place um
have a look at these pictures
here we go during the competition dogs
surf next to their owners on paddle
boards and begin a poochie's war life
vest to ensure safety
in
safety in the water first place winners
were paraffina and orona augusto caesar
uh the pair had previously won silver
and bronze medals at the world
championships who knew there was also a
world championships for dog surfing
there we go champions
very pleased with themselves
it was having a great time doesn't they
did that make you smile we hope so uh
coming up british socialite elaine
maxwell is accused of preying on young
girls at her trial in new york we'll
have the latest on that
[Music]
from the time i was a little girl i felt
this spark
this positive force that always pushed
me forward
i was like a diamond in the rough
i knew the woman i wanted to become
strong optimistic resilient
a brighter future is in all of our hands
and i believe
the best is yet to come introducing the
pandora brilliance collection lab
created diamonds
imagine if you could pick up the same
soothing emollient formula of double
bass prescribed by your gp for problem
dry skin conditions like eczema without
having to visit your doctor
it's easy to get the great double bass
treatment you trust
and there's also flare relief from
double bass a unique
hello again everyone i'm sure you're
aware that new rules have come into
force this morning requiring masks on
public transport and also in shops and
the booster program is being rapidly
expanded with the uk aiming for half a
million jabs a day and there's new
isolation rules for those who've been in
contact with people who've tested
positive for the new covid variant but
could those regulations have an impact
on families up and down the country for
christmas have it
don't know have a listen to what the
health minister jillian keegan told me
earlier on
obviously you could be it's isolated
over christmas you could be um but what
we're hoping is that you know we keep
these cases obviously everybody's going
to be contacted people start the
isolation
with or without this you could be
isolated
for christmas you know with another
variant you could your boss the health
secretary said the christmas was on
track and it was all going to be
fabulous well of course
of course christmas is on track and
actually what everyone will be there
what everybody wants for christmas is if
you haven't had your first job come and
get it if you haven't have your second
job come and get it and if you haven't
already booster come and get it when
you're asked that's all we want for
christmas
so i also asked the minister if the
government is going to struggle to stop
the extended vaccine rollout with the
aim to add an
additional million jobs to the current
two and a half million that we're always
also doing
at this time of year
we've used in the past you know nhs
staff obviously the community nursing
staff of
the pharmacies the gps volunteers
retired doctors and nurses we've used
that pool of staff in the past so i
guess they're going to be looking at
which of those they need to um you know
bring back into you're going to mobilize
an army of um of nhs people yeah i mean
you know there's a lot of i mean i don't
know you know lots of lots of uh in my
case we had lots of retired doctors and
nurses we had lots of uh community
volunteers as well who had first aid
training so we did have a lot of that in
the first and they'll get the call up
again well they'll look at what they
need to do um but you know we do have
you know the facilities we do have the
people and we do have the vaccine so
they'll just be putting the plan
together to see what's what's going to
make most
tomorrow's
sense
so is christmas on or off
well i think the message the government
are trying to get across is that we
don't know how big a threat the omicron
variant is or how effective the vaccines
are going to be so these measures which
are in place for the next three weeks
taking us to around the 20th of december
aim to slow it down while we get the
booster rollout ramped up so they want
to get 3.5 million people a week boosted
all adults over 18 who had their second
job three months ago will be eligible
and they're hoping that as a result of
all that action things will be able to
be relatively normal at christmas time
but of course there are no guarantees
because we simply don't know if it will
turn out to be very very transmissible
more so than the delta variant and we
might be in a situation of needing more
restrictions so at the moment you've got
a case where these these uh restrictions
on mask wearing for example in england
expire before christmas they don't want
to say whether they'll need to be
extended or whether people will should
be able to go to their office party or
school should be having nativity plays
these were the sort of issues being
raised by tory mps in parliament
yesterday i think the government feels
that this is up to employers and up to
schools to make these decisions they
don't want to mandate anything at the
moment or raise fears that people are
all going to be trapped in their homes
alone at christmas at this stage because
we simply don't know okay um tomorrow's
take 95 looking forward to it thank you
meantime let's get more on the new rules
aisha is at victoria train station in
central london for us are they all
wearing their mouth size she good
morning
morning terry yeah most the majority
vast majority here are wearing their
masks there are still a few people who
aren't but here at victoria they've got
an announcement playing every 10-15
minutes telling people they must wear
their face coverings in the station and
on trains as once again
face coverings on public transport in
england has become mandatory
bringing england in line with the rest
of the uk on that front and anyone not
wearing a mask risking getting fined for
it we've spoken to a couple of commuters
this morning about how they feel and the
overwhelming response is people are
happy lots of people we've spoken to
feel the government made the right call
on this in the face of the omnicom
variant but there's also people quite
indifferent to all of this as well
they're wearing masks because they have
to uh if they weren't compulsory they
wouldn't be too bothered either way
so for the next three weeks at least
face mask compulsory on public transport
okay thank you thanks a lot
opening statements have been made in the
long awaited sex trafficking trial of
the disgraced financier jeffrey
epstein's ex-girlfriend gelaine maxwell
the prosecution accused
maxwell of preying on vulnerable young
girls while the defense argued that the
charges against her were for crimes
epstein committed and she was not
jeffrey epstein joined night by uh
daphne barrack a journalist who has
interviewed delane maxwell from prison
hello to you daphne thanks for joining
us um how did you first establish
contact with her well actually funny
enough we are on sky news when i was in
my 20s rupert murdoch asked me to do it
for fox he owned sky news at the time so
it actually aired as a big scoop
with betty maxwell the big scoop was her
mother it was a first anniversary
for the death of robert maxwell
and we flew betty
to new york and
we had a bonus delay and her youngest
daughter joined us for a few days it was
a very big scoop it was two nights in
fox news it was also
it was also on sky news it was the front
page of the new york post and i'm
syndicated worldwide
um so apparently that's the only tv ever
with guilty knoxville who would have
known right
um how's she doing do you know how she
is faring she she says that she has been
um assaulted while in prison
well what i want to remind everybody kay
that she like many other prisoners uh in
america against the spirit of the
american law
are being kept without being charged so
she is right now presumed innocent
unless she's being found guilty if she's
found guilty if she did what she's
accused god forbid she should be
punished harshly but
why are we going through the trial so so
far she has been 17 months
really being held in isolation total
isolation
and in very tough conditions and it
raises a big question uh not only about
her but about other prisoners who do not
have these resources and
and costly lawyers and and are voiceless
so that's really what bothered me
um but she's a flight risk isn't she she
can't be allowed to be out on bail
and i'm glad you mentioned that case so
i'm doing the exclusive interviews for
cbs paramount series which
will be on itv uh in uk with fremental
um and uh one of our big exclusive
interviews was with matt hallier he's a
head of the security
uh
of gillane who you remember you and i
and everybody else were wondering where
is gillane
uh in the globe and basically his team
was hiding here for months not from the
authorities he said he said from
as the media and they also thought that
maybe jeffrey epstein was murdered and
they saw them maybe there was a killer
out there um so basically he claimed
that she was never a flight risk that he
the moment jeffrey epstein died and
kevin maxwell her brother asked him to
go into action he said i'm flying you
out of the country she refused he tried
again and again she refused and if you
notice k nobody revealed his name but
when they put the 28 million dollars
bail which was refused
uh one million of it uh was actually met
hollyer who was willing to put 1 million
dollar a pound
because he was so sure that she will not
escape so i mean the judge
doesn't didn't agree with him but
he's very convinced she's not a flight
risk
wasn't she hiding somewhere and the fbi
had to storm the house
so they yeah she was hiding they were
actually moving here every two weeks uh
from one place to another
but mostly you know between family and
friends um
but they claimed that she was not hiding
from the fbi but from the media she had
a new husband as you know even her
brothers didn't know but she had a new
husband step children and she thought
she didn't want them to to face uh the
media intrusion
um so basically that's her claim
um that's what her siblings are saying
and that's what the head of the security
is saying and and he believes her
and you know he knows probably better
than you and i
yeah and i'm sure my viewers will make
up their own minds um
just remind me of the charges that she's
facing
she's actually facing eight charges six
of them has to do with uh
sex abuse sex trafficking of course a
with underage girls that's a problem
because the underage is different in
different countries
um the other two is actually the the
seventh and eighth uh charges are
actually have to do with perjury that
she allegedly uh lied under oath uh when
and that has to do with the civil
lawsuits which you remember virginia
roberts uh stood here and they settled
and and the settlement is uh discrete so
let's see
yeah well
again a a different judge has a
different view on that but we'll have to
wait and see as you said uh just before
i let you go how long do you expect the
trial to last well they say six weeks um
her siblings by the way are going to
shut them back and forth there was
always somebody's there so it's long six
weeks but let's see
there may be surprise surprises with the
witnesses on the support on the
prosecution side
they are still i know it was reported
that she is going to take the stand this
is not decided yet
so six weeks is minimum including
christmas and new year's eve in the
middle and not good news for the jury
but it may be seven
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
your insight daphne much appreciated
thank you
my pleasure
thank you joshua our legal commentator
is with us now joshua rosenberg of
course um morning joshua um what's your
take on what's likely to happen over the
next few weeks
i think prosecutors and the defense are
relieved that the trial started on time
with all the complications of covet and
everything else
and the prosecution were able to outline
their case uh which is that gillane
maxwell procured girls for the convicted
pedophile jeffrey epstein
and the defense were able to outline
their case which is that he's the person
who should be in the dock and because he
killed himself while he was in prison uh
the the prosecution is simply going
after her instead
but we're now down to the evidence as
you know we've got the first witness
who's begun giving his evidence he's the
personal pilot uh who used to ferry
jeffrey epstein around and no doubt the
prosecution will try to give us some
idea of the lifestyle that epstein led
and their allegations about the
involvement of gillane maxwell
um okay something like six weeks is what
we were hearing and i also just raised
the issue there about um flight risk
that is that is why she is in prison is
it at the moment
she was denied bail because it's thought
that she has the ability and the money
to leave the united states and if she
were to do so well then she wouldn't
come back and and uh clearly she's not
been granted bail pending the trial and
i don't think she'll be granted bail
during the trial so she'll be kept in
custody but she at least is able as
you've seen to attend court wearing her
normal clothes and and to create an
impression for the jury which has to
decide crucially
whether these witnesses uh who the
prosecution have outlined there are four
uh women who were
allegedly abused by epstein uh with
galen maxwell's support these were
people who were under the age of 18 at
the time and i think crucial to the
trial is the evidence that these
witnesses are going to give
okay it's good to talk to you joshua as
always thank you
still to come the government brings in
new measures to curb the spread of the
kovich omicron variant but just how
worried should we be talking to a member
of sage and immunology after the break
that's come
[Music]
so what's going to happen to christmas
we had the health minister on the
programme a little bit earlier on and
she conceded that many of us might have
to find ourselves in quarantine
self-isolating for christmas what will
that mean for christmas plans let's
speak to professor paul moss from the
institute of immunology and
immunotherapy at the university of
berlin birmingham previously attended
stage as well of course hello to you
professor um how worried are you that
christmas might be off again
i don't think we need to worry too much
about that at this stage it's um what a
difference a week makes since we last
spoke and um
but i think as as biden actually
president biden said i think we should
be concerned but not panicking at the
current time and the measures that we
got in place have a good chance of
gaining some control here i think
is it right that if you have the omicron
variant you should uh
if you come into contact with somebody
who's had that that you should
self-isolate is that your view
yes i think that's absolutely right i
think the two ways that we're adopting
to try and control this are one in
behavioral change obviously uh reducing
transmission so the travel restrictions
more lateral flows so forth masking of
course as we talked last week and the
second big factor of course is the
immunity and we know that we may lose
some immunity with this virus so what's
happening is we are boosting our immune
levels to super high levels with the
plans that were introduced yesterday and
that should retain some protection
others say it could be that we're also
completely overreacting how quickly will
we know
um
well i think what we've seen with covet
is that things change very rapidly don't
they and i think we need at least three
weeks to assess this we need excellent
epidemiology within the laboratory
people are testing the resistance of the
virus against um vaccinated samples so
we will need that sort of time
and we will know a lot more before
christmas
um and as far as uh being more resistant
to vaccine is concerned that that is of
significant concern especially for those
that are immunosuppressant or or more or
elderly
absolutely so i mean we've talked before
about how it's like a lock and a key the
virus uses a lock to get into the key of
ourselves we've been immunized with the
the key from um the wuhan virus and now
we've got a different key it can still
get in to the lock but it's different
and there are about 30 mutations in that
key and we seen some of these before and
they do lose antibody binding but we've
never seen them all together so there is
some worry there that some of the
antibodies will be lost but there's the
other immunity the cellular immunity and
that should be largely retained so i
think there's certainly hope that
vaccines will still provide protection
against severe disease
what do we do as far as the kids are
concerned
well you've seen the the change that
came overnight about the second vaccine
for the younger children we're gradually
moving down now um 12 and upwards so um
a key factor here will be the severity
of the disease of this omicron uh you
probably saw that the doctor in south
africa who initially identified it has
seen relatively mild cases which is very
encouraging however you know that's a
much younger population as you said
yourself i mean it's the elderly
population we need to worry about south
africa only six percent above 65 years
whereas we've got a much higher
proportion
indeed so a fourth dose is what we're
hearing though for for some we've only
just heard about the booster now we're
hearing about a fourth dose again for
those who are particularly vulnerable do
you think we're going to find ourselves
in a position at least for the next two
three however many years that we may
have to have a booster every three to
six months
it's certainly possible and that with
the
mrna vaccines that we're seeing now
there is some antibody waning and yet
the boosting effect is extremely
effective we talked about this last week
over 90 protection against uh infection
with three doses so we may need them
regularly um we've also got the
astrazeneca vaccine which of course is
also excellent at cellular immunity as
well so we may need them fairly
regularly but as at the moment we don't
quite know how often that will be
if we find out that omicron is resistant
to the boosters and the vaccines that
we've already had how long does it take
to get a new one
well as you know the companies have
already started the gene has been cloned
but typically talking around 100 days i
mean when you know we've learned so much
in the last 18 months nobody felt we get
a vaccine within a year when the
pandemic started and we did we got
several so it will be accelerated and of
course if we were in that severe
situation which i really hope that we
won't get to by the way we're very well
prepared um we know what to do
and professor the expansion of these
booster doses though because for now we
have to accept that they they're what
we've got so let's work with them what
does that mean for the disparity of um
boosters and vaccinations around the
world one would have thought that you
know potentially we wouldn't be seeing
the situation in southern africa that
we're seeing now if we'd sent more doses
to them
yes that's been a very lively debate
hasn't it in the last week and indeed
for many months and i think um it's been
great to see the countries coming
together and the realization that yes
we're all in this together and we do
need much stronger global vaccination to
stop these variants from peering yeah i
agree
final thought before i let you go what
are your top tips for people trying to
keep as safe as possible leading up to
christmas obviously we've seen the new
masks coming in to force now would you
advise people potentially not to go to
christmas parties to stay as you know
within their families
um people obviously need to make their
own decisions but you're right we've got
good masking policy now for lateral
flows are very good test k we you know
they're very widely available in the uk
and so i would certainly use those
before you go to any events when mixing
with people um and you know within
reason obviously try and enjoy christmas
and see your families
okay let's see what happens it's good to
talk to you as always professor wise
words thank you very much indeed
thank you